this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
there are geeks and then there are geeks
and then there's this [ __ ] guy in the
news his name is Tom Murphy he's a
computer science PhD student come on who
has put together on YouTube it's hard to
even talk about he's taken to episode
four as it's now known from the Star
Wars world
the first Star Wars of the original
trilogy he's taking a new world he's
taking that new hope
what the [ __ ] whatever the one the good
one the one of the good ones he's taken
that film and then he's taken every word
in that film every [ __ ] word in that
film if you ever feel bad about your
life let me tell you a story about this
guy every word from that film he's
taking it separated it and then put it
in alphabetical order
or than the span of a video every uh of
the app alphabetical order of every word
in the movie this is what happens when
you never have an ejaculation in your
entire life all the energy gets spent at
just editing Star Wars into word by word
I disagree I think this is the bridge to
ejaculation because if you show this to
somebody like I offer ties every word in
Star Wars you show that to me I'd be
like zip oh come on there are eleven
thousand six hundred eighty four words
used in that film in case you were
curious only lightsaber by the way is
only used once in the film force is
spoken twenty two times the word ah is
used 240 times you'll see it in the
video when you watch it I look I I'm a
supporter of the nerd and geek culture
I'm one of them but this guy is gone too
[ __ ] far yeah you're one of them all
right you like Star Wars a new world
stop it
I'll clear this room you father it's the
story of foot solo and his hairy cat
French aw baka here's the video little
taste the video of every word from Star
Wars a new hope alphabet afraid yeah it
goes on and on like that it was like
watching a Michael Bay movie man is just
so [ __ ] cut heavy and [ __ ] house like
they're an asteroid coming that's nuts
yeah that's a lot of after I want to go
home light up and just smoke through
that whole thing cuz there's probably a
code buried in there somewhere I hope
you don't have seizures because that
will throw you right into one the Darth
Vinci Code
[Music]
you
[Music]